everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today we're in round 2 of
the u.s. Chess Championship our
competitors why it's gonna be played by
nakamura the top american by far rating
2798 one of the top players in the world
playing phenomenal chests especially
this year already won two big
tournaments his opponent playing the
black pieces is a Cobian rating 27 13 I
actually got 2nd place in this
tournament last year so no stranger to
success at the US Chess Championship so
we'll go ahead and get started Nakamura
starts out with pawn to e4 pawn to e6 so
we do see the French defense pawn d4
pawn d5 Knight c3 and then pawn takes
here on e4 not the most common typically
you're going to see a few things from
Black Knight to f6 pawn up here to e5
bringing the knight down here to d7 or
instead of the knight coming out here
with an early night to c3 because white
usually has the option just playing pawn
here to e5 but then after Knight to c3 a
lot of times you'll see the bishop
coming down here to b4 go ahead and put
a double pawn here on the C file that's
gonna be completely fine but black the
sides for a little bit different
approach two sets to go and take here on
e4 and then after the knight captures we
have not here to d7 Knight f3 besides
just developing two pieces a little bit
Nakamura does decide to go ahead and
exchange off these nights here on f6 so
Knight f6 recapturing here Bishop to d3
allowing him to castle on the King side
if he chooses and then just developing
his minor pieces pawn to a c5 opening up
the door Nakamura doesn't want to
capture here you never want to capture
and then just immediately have your
opponent recapture and gain a tempo
right here so all of a sudden black has
the center of the board controlled and
all of a sudden white doesn't have
either of a central pawn so not chemours
not going to do that but just in case
you kind of see this in your own game
don't be rushing to capture your upon
its pawns especially if they can just
recapture and kind of gain an advantage
in the center of the board Bishop here
to e3 just opening up the possibility if
he does want to castle on the Queen side
you can bring his Queen here - D - E -
and then castle on the Queen's head if
he wants to Queen here - a c7
I'm just getting that Queen involved
queen up here to e2 bishop here to e7
getting rid of the castle on the Kings
side as well and this is the one spot
where Nakamura honestly can decide to
castle Han either side it's completely
okay me personally I'm more attending to
castle on the King side it's just a
little bit safer there's a lot of action
going on the Queen side
I like black and definitely open this up
and make it very difficult on the Queen
side but cancelling on the Queen side
it's gonna be very easy to open up this
D file after the pawn takes here on c5
does have protection from this bishop
here so having the rook here on d1 could
cause a lot of problems for black so it
really just depends on preference
Nakamura does decide to go for a little
bit more of the aggressive approach he
is playing white he has to make sure
that he gets all of these wins you know
he could not lose this entire tournament
but if everyone else is beating their
opponents all of a sudden he's gonna see
himself at the bottom so he needs to
make sure that when he's playing
especially as the white pieces that he's
going for the win every time
so that's exactly it as he plays the
more aggressive move of King castling on
the Queen side here we see castle on the
Kings side from a cobia and then the
pawn takes here on c5 as we talked about
now the bishop is protecting it black
does have you know this option here just
to take with his Bishop and he does have
protection with this Queen but this is a
turning point in the game because this
kind of sets up how the rest of this
game is going to take place instead of
taking with a bishop here on c5 codeme
decides to go and play pawn to b6 giving
up material on board so after the pawn
takes the pawn recaptures b6 and bike is
pretty much played his hand he said hey
I've given up material knock'em or you
are a higher ranked player so I'm going
to beat you by opening up the Queen side
and just throwing everything i have at
you and you're gonna have to try to
defend against and not come or on the
other side decides okay let's play that
game I haven't really moved my pieces up
much it's still kind of playing
defensive mode none of his pieces have
gone past this third rank here so for
awhile Nakamura is going to have to play
defense he can't be too aggressive
the Queen sides just to open the risk
can swing over here very easily get
involved black does have a double bishop
here you can kind of a mall that over
here on the kingside so needs to be
somewhat defensive and if he can save
himself from getting checkmated early on
or some crucial mistake he's gonna be
okay in the ingame but that's kind of
what both sides are gonna be looking to
do after that move of pawn just giving
up more Myrtle here on b6o King here to
be one doesn't want to make sure that he
does protect this pawn on a2 since it is
being attacked by this rook here on a8
Bishop here to b7 opening up the door
White's gonna come over here play Knight
here to d4 definitely has to make sure
that all his material starts to focus on
the the Queen side and get just more
protection over there rook here to a5 I
don't really like this move from black I
don't think it really does too much yeah
it's kind of opening up the door for
Brooke needs to come over here to a8 but
for right now it's not doing too much
and I think it's somewhat of a wasted
move maybe Bishop here to c5 maybe
better could always just play rook to c8
could play rook here to d8 these are you
know open file and a semi open file that
these rooks are gonna be very very good
on so black does decide to go and play
rook here to a five-night here to b5
this is definitely an important square
it does have protection from this bishop
here on d3 and it's kind of a pain for
black to deal with it does force this
Queen to move and it does take some of
the squares away from this rook if you
know if it kind of wants to retreat back
here to a7 for any reason he can't
really do that
the Queen's gonna come down here to c7
or c6 safe little square it also has a
double attack on this pawn here on g2 so
that's definitely how you always want to
move if your opponent forces you to move
especially your Queen you want to
respond in a place where it actually
threatens your opponent's and now they
have to be thinking okay I can't
continue my attack I have to be worried
about this pawn or this square that
they're now attacking bishop comes back
here to a d2 forcing the rook to
so the rook is gonna come back here to a
8 and then pawn up here to f3 so
nakamura decides to go ahead and get rid
of the threat that was the rook and now
he's just going to protect this pawn
here on d2 by just playing this simple
pawn here to f3 black now plays Bishop
here to a6 and noch amol responds with
pawn to c4 and this is kind of a stake
in the ground
letting black know that why it feels
confident in his position typically if
your opponent's knowing everything at
the side of the board that you've
castled you're not going to be playing
your pawns pushing forward too much
definitely not two squares like Nakamura
is but if you kind of look at it's very
tough for black to get past this this is
a nice little diagonal from Nakamura
it's a great outpost here on b5 with his
9th his pawns protecting his bishops
protecting the pawn
it's Queens protecting all of these
pieces so it's not real clear how black
is actually going to fight through this
now he does play rook here to d8 again
as we talked about you want to get more
pieces involved into the accident
especially since blacks down and
material right now he needs to have a
very strong attack Bishop here to c3
just gonna get into a better Square this
chain right here is not really gonna
move so this is a much more central
square that's attacking more material
Queen here to see if I definitely think
this is a big mistake from black had a
few other options as far as how he
wanted to attack but the Queen here on
c5 just allows Nakamura to play Bishop
here to d4 which is a huge attack
there's not a lot of great squares the
black cannot go respond here if black
comes down and takes with his his rook
then we see the knight take if the Queen
chose to recapture we have a discovered
attack check here this Queens going to
fall definitely would not fall for that
the Queen can't come to d6 or c7 because
the knight that comes here to c6 all of
a sudden we see the bishop take after
the Bishop takes then this Bishop here
to e4 and is a discovered attack on the
rook but also it's attacking this Queen
and this rook here on a8 White's gonna
go up even more material on the board
black does decide to go ahead and play
Queen back here to CAS but again black
does not want to be
the position where White's dominating
the aggression and blacks just kind of
sitting back he's down in material so
this is definitely not going well but
then now the bishop can come here to be
six White's up in material and whites
being the aggressor so things are not
looking good for black at the moment now
rook here to d7 since it was being
attacked bishop coming back here to f2
it already took that material so it's
just gonna come back to safe zone Bishop
here to c5 not chemours completely okay
exchanging material off the board he's
now up to pawns if he can get to an in
game and he's up to pawns he's gonna win
that a hundred times out of a hundred so
the Queen takes and then the bishops
gonna come here to e4 again this is a
great central square for this Bishop
attacking the rook here if black wants
to exchange off material that's gonna be
fine we're just gonna get down to the
endgame but it also opens up the door
for these rooks to start getting
exchanged off the board rook here to of
b8 again it's not gonna matter too much
there's still this outpost piece here on
b5 being protected by the pawn and the
Queen here on e2 macklemore does a
phenomenal job this game of really using
all his pieces to defend his other
pieces while still having a very strong
attack at all points that's so hard to
do especially at this level of chess but
nakamura has been playing extremely well
lately so it doesn't shock me at all
we're taking here on d7 and the knight
recapturing so more material that black
gets off the board it's gonna be more
and more difficult for him to come back
and actually win or even tie at this
game now that works gonna swing over
here to see one again this square here
on c4 is very very valuable so wants to
make sure that does have some protection
also doesn't want to allow his opponent
to have some crazy attack we're kind of
Forks a rook in his his Kings over here
unprotected so it brings over there for
a little bit of protection not here to
f6 Bishop back here to d3 protecting
this long diagonals we talked about
paneer to g6 rook over here to d1
opening up the door if he does want to
attack on this D file Bishop takes
that's going to be fine pawn recaptures
hey if like wants to exchange Mormons
here off the board that's completely
okay night here to d5 rook here to see
one forcing the Queen back Queens gonna
come down here to d4 pawn here to g3 and
this is crucial there's a few options
that white has here blacks kind of
threatening Knight here to f4 attacking
both the bishop and the Queen so we
could see the bishop come here to see
for this is probably what I would have
played but I do think pawn to g3 it's
probably just as good but it does kind
of allow your opponent to know hey I'm
looking at every move that you could
possibly do and I'm just gonna let you
know that I'm gonna shut you off of
doing everything you do so as far as a
mental aspect I think pawn to g3 is
definitely better in that respect now
the reason I swing over here to d8
Bishop here to see four Knights coming
down here that's going to be completely
okay if white wants to exchange off the
board but decides to go and bring his
bishop back here to b3 doesn't want to
hold on to that rook appear to be eight
pawn here to a4 there's just no way for
black to really push through this look
at how well all these pieces are really
defending each other it's gonna be very
difficult for black to do too much and
white if he wants to can you know
Nakamura can start pushing his pawns
over here on the Queen side
Knight up here to f5 Queen up here to e4
Queen down here rook up here to see two
again Black's trying to attack but he
only has one real piece in the attack
zone and white just has too many pieces
here to really defend against this and
so the Queen's gonna come back here to
d8 again you don't want to be in
defensive mode especially when you're
down so much material against a strong
player pawn here to g4 Nakamura decides
to go and start attacking on the King
side pawn heared the f4 Queen up here
attacking the rook that we're just gonna
swing down here to b7 to make sure it's
not being attacked pawn up here to h4 it
there's just too much threats over here
for black to deal with Queen down here
all of a sudden pawn to h5 also
threatening pawn here to h6 and then
that would be you know checkmate here on
Queen to g7 if the Queen tried to come
back
let's see to d8 then all of a sudden
it's still gonna be very difficult with
pawn to h6 you know the the Queen's
gonna come over here and then all of a
sudden we can see a few moves just pawn
to g5 solidifying the one and two that's
fine you could also see the pawns
starting to push forward now that the
Queen here on e5 is protecting the pond
then all of a sudden blacks gonna have
to deal with these pawns over here
there's just too many threats on board
and at any time there's gonna be
checkmate by Queen here on g7 so this
Queens kind of stuck all of a sudden
there's just too much material on board
if black decided to go ahead and take
here on h5 same kind of story pawn takes
here on h5 next move is gonna be pawn
here to h6
there's just no great squares for black
to really deal with now all of a sudden
the rook can swing over here to g2 check
the king again no good options why it's
completely dominating in this position
and so black decides to go ahead and
resign so Nakamura congratulations to
him already has two wins under his belt
one is black one is white so he's
playing phenomenal chess I give a lot of
credit to you know Kobe and he knew he
was playing against a strong opponent
playing the black pieces he came in and
he was gonna give it his all and
actually try for a win and so he had
some sacrifices on the Queen side he
thought would work out but Nakamura
playing strong chess
fought off all of the stuff that black
was throwing so great game by both of
them I'm really excited just to see some
phenomenal games just through round 2 of
the US Chess Championship so hopefully
you guys are enjoying this try to have
as much coverage as I can but thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you in
the next video